visage impassible
michel fourniret marche entre deux
policiers belges devant le palais de
justice de dinan sans protection au
presque voici celui qu'on appelle ici le
dutroux france est un délinquant sexuel
condamné en france en 87 à sept ans de
prison
dénoncé aujourd'hui par sa femme pour
d'autres crimes il vient d'être entendu
par la police judiciaire de reims
désormais fournir et est soupçonné dans
une dizaine d'affaires de viol et de
meurtre
avec à chaque fois des agissements
similaires
il va repérer une de ses victimes
potentielles et puis il va soit la
trappe et lui-même à la faire monter
dans sa camionnette soit se faire aider
par sa compagne et puis va l'emmener
ailleurs parfois chez lui dans des
endroits déserts là il la viole et puis
là tu devant les enquêteurs français
aujourd'hui fournirait raconte son
parcours de criminels l'enlèvement
d'isabelle la ville en 87 à auxerre
celui d'elisabeth briché 12 ans et de
jeanne-marie disparues toutes les deux
dans la même région 89
mais il nie pour les crimes les plus
récents dont sa femme la cus pourtant
celui de céline saison ou de manana tu
ponds retrouvée morte en 2000 pour les
familles des victimes l'espoir est
pourtant là de savoir enfin ce qu'il
s'est passé
d'ailleurs même trois ans qu'on est à se
demander c'est lui c'est pas lui à jour
ses huits un jour c'est no bon c'était
dur c'est c'est affreusement durée
rodrigue s'arrête quoi certes custine en
belgique la dernière demeure de fournir
et avant son arrestation
l'an dernier les voisins découvrez avec
effroi avoir côtoyé un pédophile on
parle maintenant de serial killer savas
qui a été bizarre des enfants
ce soir michel fourniret est soupçonné
dans une dizaine d'affaires criminelles
en france et en belgique mais les
enquêteurs restent prudents il faut
maintenant vérifier les aveux du
pédophile
[Musique]